[موسيقى]
انهم متوترون اولا لان كل الدول التي لها
علاقه بهذا الصراع الروسي الاوكراني لها
اهتمام عميق بنوع السلاح الذي يملك الطرف
الاخر من النزاع المانيا هي مثال جيد
فلديها كم كبير من دبابات وعمرها 20 30
عاما وقد اظهرت الصور وهم اظهروها وهي في
مستودعاتها لقد فككت كلها وتقول المانيا
لدينا المئات من هذه التجهيزات لكن
المشكله ان جزءا منها لا يعمل بالنسبه الى
روسيا فان الامر هو عكس ذلك روسيا تحتفظ
بكل شيء وحتى اوكرانيا لذلك يمكن القول
اننا راينا نفس الجيل من الدبابات او جل
التجهيزات لدى الطرفين الان سيبدا الروس
بادخال تجهيزاتهم الجديده الى الميدان
سواء الطائرات المقاتله او الدبابات او
انظمه السلاح الحديثه اما الاوكرانيون
فسيقومون بشيء نفسه
ما يختلف هذا العام هو ان الامر سيتعلق
بزبله الزبده من احدث العتاد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
معروفه بكونها مقرا لاضخم المنشاه النوويه
في اوروبا وتم قصفها واستهدافها ثم
السيطره عليها من قبل قوات الاتحاد الروسي
في بدايه الاحداث العمل الماضي فان القلق
يساور الجميع بشانها بشان او بسبب احتمال
تسرب النووي كل ذلك لا يجعلني في نفس
الوقت تعتقد ان القوات الاوكرانيه ستركز
على منطقه محدده تعرفون ان هناك الكثير من
الحديث بشان الهجوم الاوكراني لكن تقديري
ان الامر لن يتعلق بهجوم اوكراني ولكن
بهجمات اوكرانيه سيهاجمون عده مناطق سواء
بكيفيه متزامنه اول واحده تلو الاخرى
مهمه نعم وسيكونون سعداء باستعادتها مع
منشاتها النبويه خاصه لكن ذلك سيحتوي على
مخاطره بان يتسبب بحادث نووي لن يخطط له
لاروس ولا الاوكرانيون ولكن عندما تطلق
الصواريخ عليك ان تستعد لاحتمال ان يصيب
احدها منشاه لم تخطط لاصابتها حتى لو كان
لديك اكثر انظمه الاستهداف دقه
[موسيقى]